hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to human now yes I know I
don't have my beard back yet that's not
something that I can control
I don't grow facial hair very quickly so
let's just move on and deal with a few
videos from the prepubescent larval
stage of markiplier and move on with our
lives anyway this game is called human
and apparently the following footage was
captured during an attempt to hack and
record a government video stream
previously captured footage suggest the
man filming Paul works for a secret
sector frequency testing facility
located deep in the Alaskan wilderness
the program is no longer being funded
thus Paul is sent to notify the
employees and have them leave the
premises as the supervisors monitor what
unfolds once he arrives I've taken the
liberty of subtitling the video but
other than that this footage is
completely untouched so as you can see
we're kind of in a Deep Web area the
game as you can see by these lovely not
quite working tabs up there but this
wait I gotta go back and find the
attendants and turn off the powers of a
why and how
oh god I'm playing oh oh yes oh yes
please that snow actually looks
legitimately good this is made on the
Unreal Engine let's just skip that out
of the way me talking about the graphics
of it like hey looks good like the style
of it
looks pretty cool let's get into the
thick of it now what I don't know is why
I'm up in the Alaskan wilderness or why
there's a face up in the Alaskan
wilderness to begin with and also who am
i working for again some secret sector
of some not government agency trying to
break into a government video stream I'm
not I represent sure what all that means
but I'm gonna go for it then I can
sprint and also something about antennas
what the hell am I looking at oh man
those are stains I thought those are
like drawings of people like with
walking sticks and whatnot oh yeah it
seems safe no security checkpoint at all
no guard at the door just a one lit door
in the middle of a funnel it's a [ __ ]
death funnel it's a chain-link death
funnel pointing me into the death
building where I got to go turn off the
death antennas alright fine whatever
let's do this ain't no [ __ ] hello is
anybody home ah that's Andy yes a
flashlight I do I do like when I have
that thing okay
hello seems awfully wet in here blah
drips and noises happening the drips are
getting louder okay
kind of weird-ass building isness why is
there no reception area what the hell is
this thing is that an intercom urges or
radio on the wall for ambience whatever
someone knocking oh that's me okay never
mind
Zeta sector key card required well I
don't have as a - sector key card all I
got is what I got on me loo is anybody a
VA's a tit
key card Zeta sector key card oh [ __ ]
that wasn't this door oh is that hello
I'd like to assume that I'm here alone
but that would be a logical considering
this should be a government facility
with people working and possibly a lot
of them also I can't fathom what the
point of these you know what I'm done
questioning things I get it I understand
I'm about to die I know this I I should
just accept my fate keel over and just
kiss my ass good-bye hello Oh although
our focus in the past few years has been
primarily in our rural research we have
observed a noticeable difference in
climates since a research began nearly a
decade ago due to our experimentation we
cannot say our antennas are capable of
controlling climate or weather but they
certainly have the ability to influence
changes in the own ionosphere thus
modifying weather patterns slightly I'd
also like this particular research
logged note in the past few weeks a
little frequency output has been much
higher suggesting an atmospheric source
is wirelessly feeding power to them at
the moment we have not yet identified
the source well that's weird
and tenez being powered from space oh is
that a Zeta sector keycard I see
I got a Zeta sector keycard nothing can
possibly go wrong with it
[Music]
okay I must skedaddle I'm a skid today
okay I've been I've been stalked by a
lot of things in my horror game days but
never have I had a locker come after me
I give you bonus points just for
creativity what the fudge oh okay
oh oh hi I'm listening hello
okay okay maybe I maybe I didn't take
this as seriously as I should have
hello excuse me I don't know what that
was all right everything's fine
I think I farted I'm not sure what that
was okay ah excuse me
this game is expressly [ __ ] with me
I'm not ignoring you
I I'm trying to pay attention very much
okay
Lou oh oh oh here are the employees oh
is that me was I just clearing up some
sniffles hmm
Oh
okay ah that's not good Oh none of this
is good okay okay
okay all right the [ __ ] don't be so
noisy all right all of our equipment has
recently been turning off all at once as
though we were a power surge however
when the event occurs nothing unusual
seems to be the cause on side no we have
been experiencing frequency interference
in recent weeks this has caused us to
slow down research efforts since we have
no control over experimentation when
this happens using one of our
spectrograms we have recorded an odd
signal which we believed to be the
source of the interference some of us
suspect it could be Russian others think
it may just be excessive ambient energy
this doesn't explain where it's coming
from however but where is it coming from
is it still spaced at least they have
steam oh that's not steam nevermind then
I thought those steam ah ah
are you talking about me or them cuz
that could be either of us blue boy oh
boy oh no what am I gonna do it's
blocked by an immovable desk please
this is Oh oh no oh no oh no no no
[Music]
that's not my footsteps it's not me I
don't like this I got bad feeling about
this hang on my nose running what was
that it was like a giant fuzz ball hey
come back here whatever the [ __ ] you
were Oh which way do I go do I go where
the fuzz ball win or do I go to the door
that's probably not gonna go anywhere
I'll go to the fuzz ball hey fuzz [ __ ]
fuzz but now that's a cute name [ __ ] you
that's why I'm sorry
thank you I suppose not ever accenture
if I should thank you no not even a
little bit in fact now that I know that
there's radios on this way I'm gonna go
to the door and see what that is blood
ah okay
alright just gonna ignore that that
never happened gonna try to go to this
door over here
fada sector keycard require well [ __ ] oh
thank you that's very convenient of you
I should have gone that way first
hopefully no blood got in my hair then
yeah hello I saw that I wasn't looking
down there at first but I saw that hello
what do we have nice book nikola tesla
and apparently this is red why is
everything red Oh okay I'm not an idiot
that wasn't in front of me and then was
anything that was not in front of me
that wasn't why I'm in a different place
[Music]
okay the frequency interference
continues we have not done any work for
the past four days no one has left for
some reason I feel as though we're drawn
to this place we must stay sleep has
been difficult or sanity seems to be
slipping I feel numb yet cold I didn't
feel I know less than I once did my
memories my knowledge my intelligence
what is this I don't know but apparently
it's affecting me too which is even
weirder like I got to admit I went into
this because on the surface it looked
like you know any other organ that of
God damn it I need to go back where am I
I don't need to go that way oh geez okay
yes here because there was another one
in here the frequency interference we've
been experiencing seems to be coming
from below the surface of the earth
we've not yet pinpointed the location
but we're picking up more activity on
our sonic monitoring equipment I've not
experienced this but others have been
complaining of hearing high-pitched
ringing not in the ears like tinnitus
but in their mind is in an internal
sound they can't seem to get rid of our
theories perhaps some of the sensitive
some are sensitive to these frequencies
so much that it's capable of physically
or psychologically affecting them
perhaps and then you overhear in its
hollow ski when you're over here then
you go over here
it's one more door I got like I said I
got mad I went into this going like oh
this looks so typical but this is really
cool you're not gonna talk to me now huh
who's lied to me because the only one
that's talking to me is you and I have
no idea who else wants me to turn off
antennas over here also what the hell is
going on here okay let's see I'm unsure
of what's real I'm gonna upload this to
our clothes Network as I've been
instructed where you may read it I see
no point however no research has been
done we're waiting we can't leave why
can't we leave a try and try the door
never gets any closer this can't be real
this is not reality I don't know if I'm
hallucinating it says there's another
world so the voice is talking to you too
so the voice is something coming from
underground that's broadcasting a
frequency that this new technology that
they were trying to manipulate is
affecting and apparently they cannot
escape yeah more blood don't know why
there's so much blood
bleeding all over the place the way
blood do okay don't get up don't need to
get up it's just me
your buddy I got a theta keycard good a
door it's a door we've opened the
frequency it communicates with us we
brought it here and you knew it was
going to happen we can't leave because
it it's not let us leave you knew this
would happen it's a portal takes your
mind not mine anymore
Oh
anybody over here know again my my
footsteps are very sloppy
something is behind me
[Music]
there's two sets of footprints walking
at the same time something's behind me
[Music]
something's behind me okay all right
there's there's my boots and then
there's that wet slappy I was wondering
why it was so wet and slappy Suns by me
you know what I mean yeah okay that
didn't happen okay
so I don't know if that's just in my
mind but then again if it is that's
another really good thing about the
designer this game is because I'm pretty
sure there's nothing walking like
immediately behind me as totally not
cool but might what is that hello hi how
are you doing what are you doing who are
you who are you and what are you and
what is that okay goodbye oh no you're
still there okay
oh geez
Oh God oh hi oh where am i I don't think
I will
I don't want to be immortal if this is a
life I have to live whoa jeez
okay okay but what if you're a
fabrication because I don't why don't
know you but I know you're talking to me
maybe you're not
everything's goddamn line this is just
darkness I don't like this what is that
noise also if you notice the mushy
footprints behind me they they're no
more yeah no more slaps
oh boy oh hi oh hi I do a little bit you
know these symbols are a little off it
feeds came from my soul our soul soul is
not safe any soul all soul so what was
down this way if I may be so bold
nothing oh it's a whole lot of nothing
that's there's nothing for here the only
way to go is over here and I got a
question my sandy I'm not gonna step in
those okay never mind I didn't have a
choice apparently it's the only way to
zipped up okay never mind then is this
puzzle what are we doing here
oh that is weird
it's an odd sensation
okay I'm back at the beginning well that
didn't work where am I going oh gosh
okay so that wasn't right I I
accidentally went the correct directions
hip no that's not 100 I made it I think
I'm not sure is this a Triforce of
courage lost souls says goodbye okay
it's the haunted lockers come back to
kill me they should have a [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh oh my god oh my god oh
okay okay I know that's true oh I really
don't know what to make of this this is
bizarre
this is weird do I have a choice here
what happen if I walk back
nope that doesn't seem to do anything
okay all right let's do it full whole
hog here I'm ready
embrace me with your open arms I am
ready I'll be treated like a god sure
okay I'm getting as close as I can
acquaint myself with this oh that was
awesome that was awesome that was like
awesome that was awesome that was
awesome that was amazing and this game
was free that was awesome
what a full game like that those so cool
I mean obviously they did the best they
could with what they had because there
wasn't any like animation of enemy
characters or anything like that the
most add was like things flying around
before what they did and what they
created out of the sound and the
environment and the ambience and the
story which was well written and well
told they did good that was good that
was really good I don't know if there's
another ending there didn't seem like it
I was trying to go back and nothing was
happening so I think that's what it is
so either way thank you everybody so
much for watching this game is really
really cool I want to see more of this
from the developers so I cannot wait for
more so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
buh-bye
[Music]